so if we can uh just link on Twitter and
Elon before I would love to talk to you
about the underlying business model
Wikipedia which is This brilliant bold
move at the very beginning but let's
since you mentioned Twitter what do you
think works what do you think is broken
about Twitter
I mean it's a long conversation but to
to start with one of the things that I
always say is it's a really hard problem
so I can see that right up front I said
this about you know the old ownership of
Twitter and the new ownership of Twitter
because unlike Wikipedia and this is
true actually for for all social media
there's a box and the Box basically says
what do you think what's on your mind
you can write whatever the hell you want
right this is true by the way even for
for YouTube I mean the boxes to upload a
video but again it's just like an
open-ended invitation to express
yourself and what makes that hard is
some people have really toxic really bad
you know some people are very aggressive
they're actually stalking they're
actually you know abusive and suddenly
you deal with a lot of problems
whereas at Wikipedia there is no box
that says what's on your mind there's a
box that says
this is an entry about
the Moon
please be neutral please cite your facts
then there's a talk page which is not
coming rant about Donald Trump if you go
on the talk page of the Donald Trump
entry and you just start ranting about
Donald Trump people will say what are
you doing like stop doing that like
we're not here to discuss like there's a
whole world of the internet out there
for you to go and rant about Donald
Trump it's just not fun to do on
Wikipedia somehow it's fun on Twitter
well also on Wikipedia people are going
to say stop yeah and actually are you
here to tell us like how can we improve
the article are you just here to rant
about Trump because that's not actually
interesting so because the goal is
different so that's just admitting and
saying up front this is a hard problem
certainly
um I'm I'm writing a book on trust so
the idea is
um you know in the last 20 years we've
lost trust you know uh in all kinds of
Institutions and politics you know the
the Adelman trust barometer survey has
been done for a long time and you know
trust in politicians trust in journalism
it's it's come declined substantially
and I think in many cases deservedly
so how do we restore trust and how do we
think about that and uh does that also
include
trust in the idea of Truth
trust in the idea of Truth like even the
concept of facts and Truth is really
really important and the idea of
uncomfortable truths is really important
now so when we when we look at
um Twitter right and we say we can see
okay this is really hard
so here here's my my story about Twitter
it's two-part story
um and it's all pre-elon musk ownership
so many years back somebody uh accused
me of horrible crimes on on Twitter and
I you know like anybody would I it's
like you know I'm in the public eye
people say bad things I don't really you
know I brush it off whatever but I'm
like this is actually really bad like
accusing me of pedophilia like that's
just not okay so I thought I'm gonna
report this so I click report I report
the tweet and there's five others and I
go through the process and then I get an
email it says you know whatever a couple
hours later saying uh thank you for your
report we're looking into this great
okay good then several hours further I
get an email back saying sorry we don't
see anything here to violate our terms
of use
okay so I emailed Jack and I said Jack
come on like this is ridiculous and he
emails back roughly saying
um yeah sorry Jimmy don't worry we'll
sort this out
and I just thought to myself you know
what that's not the point right I'm
Jimmy Wales I Know Jack Dorsey I can
email Jack Dorsey he'll listen to me
because he's got an email from me and
sorts it out for me what about the
teenager who's being bullied uh and is
getting abuse right and getting
accusations that aren't true are they
getting the same kind of like really
poor result in that case so fast forward
a few years
same thing happens
um the exact quote only goes
um
please help me I'm only 10 years old and
Jimmy Wells raped me last week it's like
come on off like that's ridiculous
so I report I'm like this time I'm
reporting but I'm thinking well we'll
see what happens this one gets even
worse because
then I get a same result email back
saying sorry we don't see any problems
so I raise it with other members of the
board who I know and Jack and like this
is really ridiculous like this is
outrageous
and some of the board members friends of
mine sympathetic and so good for them
but I actually got an email back then
from The General Counsel head of trust
and safety saying actually there's
nothing in this tweet that violates our
terms of service we don't regard uh and
and gave reference to the metoo movement
if we didn't allow accusations the metoo
movement it's an important thing and I
was like you know what actually if
someone says I'm 10 years old and
someone raped me last week I think the
advice should be here's the phone number
of the police like you need to get the
police involved it's not the place for
that accusation
so even back then by the way they did
delete those tweets but I mean the
rationale they gave spammy Behavior
right so completely separate from
abusing me it was just like oh well they
were retweeting too often okay whatever
so like that's just broken like that's a
system that it's not working for people
in the public eye I'm sure it's not
working for private people who get abuse
really horrible abuse can happen
so how is that today well it hasn't
happened to me
um since Elon took over but I don't see
why it couldn't and I suspect now if I
send a report and email someone there's
no one there to email me back because
he's gotten rid of a lot of the trust
and safety staff so I suspect that
problem is still really hard just
content moderation at huge scales has
huge scales is really something and I
don't know the full answer to this I
mean a piece of it could be
um you know to say actually making
specific allegations of crimes uh this
isn't the place to do that you know
we've got a huge database if you've got
an accusation of crime here's who's your
call the police the FBI whatever it is
it's not to be done in public and then
you do face really complicated questions
about metoo movement and people coming
forward in public and all of that but
it's again it's like probably you should
talk to a journalist right probably
there are better Avenues than just
tweeting uh from an account that was
created 10 days ago obviously set up to
abuse someone so I think they could do a
lot better
um but I also admit it's a hard problem
and there's also ways to indirectly or
more humorously or more mocking way to
make the same kinds of accusations in
fact the accusations you mentioned if I
were to guess don't go that Viral
because they're not funny enough or
cutting enough but if you make it witty
and cutting and and uh meme it somehow
yeah yeah sometimes actually indirectly
for sure making the accusation versus
directly making acquisition that can go
viral and they can destroy reputations
and yeah and you you get to watch
yourself
uh just all kinds of narratives takes
take hold yeah no I mean I remember
another uh case that didn't bother me
because it wasn't of that nature uh but
somebody was saying you know
I'm sure you you're making millions off
of Wikipedia I'm like no actually I
don't even work there I have no salary
um and they're like you're lying I'm
gonna check your 990 form which is the
US form for
tax reporting for Charities
yeah here's the link go go read it and
you'll see I'm listed as a board member
and my salary is listed as zero so
um you know so you know things like that
it's like okay that one that feels
like you're wrong but I can take that
and I can we can have that debate quite
quickly and again it didn't go viral
because it was kind of silly and if
anything would have gone viral it was me
responding but that's one where it's
like actually I'm happy to respond
because a lot of people don't know
that I don't work there and that I don't
don't make millions uh and I'm not a
billionaire well they must know that
because it's in most news media about me
but uh the other one I didn't respond to
publicly because it's like
Barbra Streisand effect you know it's
like sometimes calling attention to
someone who's abusing you who basically
has no followers and so on it's just a
waste and everything you describing now
is just something that all of us have to
kind of learn
um because everybody's in the public eye
I think uh when you have just two
followers and you get bullied by one of
the followers it starts just as much as
we have a large number so it's not your
situation I think is echoed in the
situations of millions of other
especially teenagers and kids and so on
yeah I mean it's actually
um
uh an example uh so we don't generally
use my picture in the banners anymore on
Wikipedia but we did
um and then we did an experiment one
year where we tried other people's
pictures so one of our developers
and you know one got lovely very sweet
guy and he doesn't look like your
immediate thought of a nerdy Silicon
Valley developer he looks like a heavy
metal dude because he's cool and uh so
suddenly here he is with long hair and
tattoos and and there's there's his sort
of say here's what your money goes for
here's my my letter asking for support
and he got massive abuse from Wikipedia
like calling him creepy and you know
like really massive
and this was being shown to 80 million
people a day his picture not the abuse
right the abuse was Elsewhere on the
internet
and he he was bothered by it and I
thought you know what there is a
difference I actually am in the public
eye yeah I get huge benefits from being
in the public eye I go around and make
public speeches if any random thing I
think of I can write and get it
published in the New York Times and you
know I have this interesting life he's
not a public figure and so actually he
wasn't mad at us he wasn't he was just
like yeah actually suddenly being thrust
in the public eye and you get suddenly
lots of abuse which normally I think you
know if you're a teenager and somebody
in your class is abusing you it's not
going to go viral so you're only gonna
it's gonna be hurtful because it's local
and it's your classmates or whatever
but when when sort of ordinary people go
viral in some abusive way it's really
really quite tragic I don't know and
even at a small scale it feels viral
when the fireplace right yeah five
people at your school and there's a
rumor and there's this feeling like
you're surrounded and nobody and the
feeling of loneliness I think
which you're speaking to when you don't
have a plot when you at least feel like
you don't have a platform to defend
yourself yeah and then this
powerlessness that I think a lot of
teenagers definitely feel and a lot of
people I think you're right and that I I
think even when just like two people
make up stuff about you or lie about you
or say mean things about your bully you
that can feel like a crowd yeah yeah
that's it and it's a I mean whatever
that is in our genetics and our biology
and our the way our brain works it just
can be a terrifying experience and
um
somehow to correct that I mean I think
because everybody feels the pain of that
everybody suffers the pain that I think
will be forced to fix that as a society
to figure out a way around that I think
it's really hard to fix because I don't
think that problem isn't necessarily new
um you know someone
in
High School who writes
graffiti that says Bucky has a and
spreads a rumor about what Becky did
last weekend that's always been damaging
it's always been hurtful and that's uh
those kinds of attacks there's uh all
the time itself people see the internet
now what do you think about this
technology that feels
Wikipedia like which is community notes
on Twitter do you like it uh yeah pros
and cons do you think it's scalable I do
like it I don't know enough about
specifically how it's implemented to
really have a very deep view but I do
think it's quite it's the uses I've seen
of it I've I found quite good and in
some cases uh
changed my mind uh you know it's like I
see something and of course you know the
the sort of human tendency is
uh to retweet something
that you
hope is true or that you are afraid is
true or you know it's like that kind of
quick mental action
and then you know I saw something that I
liked and agreed with and then a
community note under it that made me
think oh actually
this is a more nuanced issue so I like
that
um I think that's really important now
how is it specifically implemented is it
scalable that I don't really know how
they've done it so I can't really
comment on that but in general I do
think it's
um you know when you're when you're only
mechanisms on Twitter uh and you're a
big Twitter user you know we know the
platform and and you've got plenty of
followers and all of that the only
mechanisms are retweeting
replying
blocking
it's a pretty limited scope and it's
kind of good if there's a way to elevate
a specific thoughtful response and it
kind of goes to again like does the
algorithm just pick the retweet or the I
mean retweeting it's not even the
algorithm that makes it viral like you
know if uh Palo cuello
um very famous author I think it's got
like I don't know I haven't looked
lately he used to have eight million
Twitter followers I think I looked he's
got 16 million now or whatever well if
he retweets something it's going to get
seen a lot or Elon Musk if you retweets
something it's going to get seen a lot
that's not an algorithm that's just the
way the platform works so it is kind of
nice if you have something else and how
that something else is designed that's
obviously
complicated question well there's a
there's an interesting thing that I
think Twitter is doing but I know
Facebook is doing for sure which is
really interesting so you have what are
the signals that a human can provide at
scale like in Twitter's retweet
um in Facebook I think you can share I
think yeah but there's basic
interactions you can have comment and so
on yeah but there's also in Facebook and
YouTube has this too is um
would you like to see more of this or
would you like to see less of this they
post that sometimes and the thing that
the the neural net that's learning from
that has to figure out is the intent
behind you saying I want to see less of
this did you see too much of this
content already uh you like it but you
don't want to see so much of it uh
you've already figured it out good great
or does this content not make you feel
good there's so many interpretations
that I'd like to see all of this but if
you get that kind of signal this
actually can create a really
um
powerfully curated
uh list of content that is fed to you
every day that doesn't it doesn't create
an echo chamber or a silo that actually
just makes you feel good yeah in the in
the good way which is like it challenges
you but it doesn't exhaust you it'll
make you kind of this this is this a
weird animal I've been saying for a long
time if I went on Facebook one morning
and they said oh we're testing a new
option
rather than showing you things we think
you're going to like we want to show you
some things that we think you will
disagree with but which we have some
signals that suggest it's of quality
like now that sounds interesting yeah
that sounds really interesting I want to
see something where you know like oh I
don't I don't agree with so uh Larry
lessig is a good friend of mine founder
of Creative Commons and he's moved on to
doing stuff about corruption and
politics and so on and I don't always
agree with Larry but I always grapple
with Larry because he's so interesting
and he's so thoughtful that even when we
don't agree I'm like actually I want to
hear him out right because I'm going to
learn from it and that doesn't mean I
always come around to agreeing with him
but I'm going to understand a
perspective and that's really a great
feeling yeah there's this interesting
thing on social media where people kind
of accuse others of saying well you
don't want to hear opinions that you
disagree with their ideas you disagree
with I think this is something that's
thrown at me all the time the reality is
there's literally almost nothing I enjoy
more
odd thing to accuse you of because if
you have quite a wide range of long
conversations with a very diverse bunch
of people but there is a very
there is like a a very harsh drop off
because what I like is high quality
disagreement that really makes you think
yeah and at a certain point there's a
threshold it's a kind of a gray area
when the quality of the disagreement it
just sounds like mocking you're not
really interested in a deep
understanding of the topic or you
yourself don't seem to carry deep
understanding of the topic like uh
there's something called uh intelligent
Square debates yeah the main one is the
British version with the British accent
everything everything always sounds
better and the Brits seem to argue more
intensely like they're uh invigorated
they're energized by the debate those
people I often disagree with basically
everybody involved and it's so fun I
learned something that's high quality if
we could do that if there's some way for
me to click a button that says
um
filter out lower quality just today it
sometimes show it to me because I want
to be able to but today I'm just not in
the mood for the mockery yeah just high
quality stuff even because even even
flatter I wanna I wanna get high quality
Arguments for the Flat Earth it would
make me feel good because I'll see oh
that's really interesting like I never
really thought in my mind to challenge
the mainstream Narrative of uh uh of
general relativity right of uh of a
perception of physics maybe all of
reality maybe all of all of space-time
is an illusion
that's really interesting I never really
thought about let me consider that fully
okay what's the evidence how do you test
that what is uh what are the
Alternatives how would you be uh able to
have such consistent perception of a
physical reality if it's all of it is an
illusion uh all of us seem to share the
same kind of perception or reality like
what like that's the kind of stuff I
love but not like the mockery of it you
know that uh the the cheap that it seems
that uh social media can kind of inspire
yeah I I I talk sometimes about how
people assume that like the big debates
in Wikipedia or the the sort of
arguments are between the party of the
left and the party of the right and I
say no it's actually the party of the
kind and thoughtful in the party of the
jerks is really is really it I mean left
and right like yeah bring me somebody I
disagree with politically as long as
they're thoughtful kind we're gonna have
a you know a real discussion I I give an
example of
um our article on abortion
so you know if you can bring together a
kind and thoughtful Catholic priest and
a kind and thoughtful Planned Parenthood
activist
and they're gonna work together on the
Oracle on abortion
uh that can be a really great thing if
they're both kind and thoughtful like
that's the important part they're never
going to agree on the topic but they
will understand okay like Wikipedia is
not going to take aside but Wikipedia is
going to explain what the debate is
about and we're going to try to
characterize it fairly and it turns out
like you're kind and thoughtful people
even if they're quite ideological like a
Catholic priest is generally going to be
quite ideological on the subject of
abortion
but they can grapple with ideas and they
can discuss and they they may feel very
proud of the entry at the end of the day
not because they suppress the other
side's views but because they think the
case has been stated very well that
other people can come to understand it
and if you're highly ideological you
assume I think naturally if people
understood as much about this as I do
they'll probably agree with me you may
be wrong about that but that's often the
case so so that's where you know that's
what I think we need to encourage more
of in society generally is is grappling
with ideas in a really
um
in a thoughtful way